c'est en observant les paysages chilien
du désert d'atacama lors d'un voyage que
l'artiste belge décident de travailler
sur les liens entre la terre le cosmos à
la suite d'un travail de recherche
elle identifie l'eau comme élément pour
associer les deux sa rencontre avec une
astronome achève la détermination de son
thème pour cette exposition notamment
une astronome de l'université de liège
en belgique qui m'a dit tiens si tu
cherches un petit peu travaillé avec
l'eau du devrait peut-être intéressé aux
lunes de jupiter les certaines nouvelles
découvertes qui ont trouvé ce une des
lunes de jupiter europa un océan qui
seraient emprisonnées entre la croûte je
l'aide de l'europe à deuxième source
d'inspiration le lieu d'exposition lui
même gwendoline robin a cherché à
exploiter la lumière et la hauteur de la
galerie ainsi que les capacités de la
galerie traversante tout quand j'ai
juste et spa j'avais envie de travailler
sur cette lune de fruyt pour aider le
public à comprendre ce qui a nourri son
imaginaire
l'artiste expose également une série de
photos de ces pistes de recherche
c'est un peu tous des paysages hors
norme avec des matières des déserts de
sel geyser qui m'ont vraiment inspiré
pour créer cette nouvelle pièce
l'exposition s'accompagne d'une série de
performances il faut évoluer l'offre
globale ou haendel ou drogba aime jouer
avec les matières et le son
pour la prochaine et dernière
performance du 16 novembre
elle s'associe avec la chorégraphe
gaëlle bourges et le musicien stéphane
monteiro autour de cette installation
certains de ses tubes contiennent d'une
mèche pyrotechnique qui produira des
sons dans toutes les directions